what's up guys it's jake this is the
34th ever
episode of the iced coffee hour
and so far we've made 30 or they've made
32
766 dollars beautiful thank you man
thank you it's a group effort to uh come
up with that number
yeah and jack does all the editing
behind the scenes so
oh man yeah good job on that it is we
are so excited to have you
on the podcast i've been watching your
videos lately they're really good
and uh super stoked to have you on both
of us have
in fact you came up on my youtube
algorithm
and immediately i'm like who are you
and i was so intrigued by your editing
your video style that you were in la and
i'm like
immediately i sent the video to jack and
i'm like we gotta have you on
because you have a really interesting
story but you combine that with just
just really
cinematic look and just this ease of
storytelling
that you're really talented but you you
have such a just intense past
so would you mind telling us a little
background on yourself
and for anybody who's who's tuning in to
you the first time just just
some of your background and uh you're
living in a car right now right
yep yep i've been doing that since march
23rd of 2019
so a long time and uh
yeah um dnf student in school
right so same here welcome to the club
yeah
yeah i grew up you know i struggled with
a lot of uh mental illnesses
and uh that kind of led to eventually
um going into drug use and so my drug
use
um got me to florida because i ended up
having to go to rehab
um for a couple times and so uh
i ended up staying out there for like a
year or so and then
randomly one day i was like i'm not i'm
not saving enough money i'm not making
enough money
and so i started looking up youtube
videos about living in your car and i
was fascinated by it the van lifers the
car lifers
and i was like i think i could do this
you know
and so one day i just packed up all my
stuff which which wasn't
much you know and i just went for it and
i
haven't looked back since pretty much
why los angeles which is arguably like
the most expensive housing
anywhere in the united states it's one
of the most expensive cities with the
highest tax rate
how do you decide that like la is where
you want to be
well i there's only really three places
that
i wanted to go florida i'd already been
texas
amazing tax no state tax whatever um in
california
but i procrastinated i procrastinated
for so many different reasons um but
eventually it just got to
i kind of want to try to take my youtube
channel to the next level
and just do something sporadic that
would maybe
get more attention or something and uh
that's pretty much the whole entire
reason why
i came over here so tell us a little bit
about the car you're living in how were
you able to make that work
um so right before i came to california
i was actually living in austin texas
um i was having some neck issues because
i was
actually sleeping just in my front seat
um i did that for the first year
of living in my car and so i was like i
kind of want to like
build something in my car that's more
comfortable and so i
i got on facebook and uh found a group
for austin texas new people and uh ended
up meeting this guy
and uh he helped me build build a bed in
my car
and so the whole entire uh passenger
side of my car
was is stripped out and then we built
this platform that's a flat surface
that i can lay memory foam on top of and
sleep
yeah that's really neat now do you tint
your windows
or how does how does this work so this
is an ongoing thing
on my channel uh where um people are
always telling me yeah jake
tint your windows or whatever and it's
just kind of like a joke i honestly i
don't know why but i don't care
really i don't care if people watch you
when you're sleeping i
i guess not no i just it doesn't bother
me like if someone's gonna look in my
car or whatever
like cool dude that's weird but like
do your thing i guess you know but i
guess i i'm thinking like if i were
walking down the street and i see
someone say
like i would not watch them i wouldn't
watch anybody sleeping in the car
yeah i mean neither would i i mean
people would i would be paranoid i'd
think the same thing i'd be like i
couldn't fall asleep just in case like i
wake up like my biggest fear is waking
up and there's someone like in the woods
oh my god that would be terrible has
that ever happened to you
uh no no okay no what about cops do cops
ever like approach you in your car or
anything like that like if you've been
parked anywhere for a while
uh just a couple of times but they've
always been like
super cool about it you know um now
mostly it's just like homeless people
knocking
on my window asking for money um
and that's really it i really haven't
had a lot of issues with
as far as people you know and do you
just pick like the nicest places to park
since you can choose wherever you want
to live
i try i try to do my best here in l.a
it's been kind of weird because like
in texas i could have one or two spots
and and be good
here in california you kind of gotta
move around a little bit
um and so i do try to find
the nice spots you know but sometimes
there's security at the nice spot so
it's always hit or miss now let's talk
briefly about
what you do for work now i've seen your
channel
postmates is one of the is it one of the
main sources of income for you
yes post mates ubereats and doordash
okay
are the primaries and then uh i'm just
now
beginning to make money on youtube so
i'm gonna tell you right now
pretty soon youtube is gonna pay you a
lot of money i just i know how many
subscribers do you have right now
like 20. 25
25 no 24 5 but you doubled
in the past couple of weeks yeah yeah
it's like tripled and you will continue
to triple
now what about monetization do you have
monetization turned on i do
okay yeah how does that work with an
address because youtube wanted
youtube has to send you like like a pin
to verify a physical address how did you
do that po box uh no so i was actually
living
in texas at the time that i monetized my
channel and so i was staying with one of
my homeboys
and uh i got it mailed to his house and
i just i waited for it
yeah you're about to blow up man like
i'm happy we got you on the podcast now
it's gonna be difficult to pull you i in
six months i guarantee a year from now
you will be an entirely different spot
like you will be in a different position
financially
you are gonna be in just a different
tier i know your channel is going to
like
blow up i really feel it i appreciate it
yeah
i mean i i don't see it right now i'm
just having fun you know i didn't go
into this intending to
like do money i just liked picking up
the camera and documenting my life
you know pretty much but how much can i
ask how much you're making right now
from
from postmates and ubereats and delivery
like in an average day
so i get pretty upset if i don't make
like uh
more than 100 a day okay um
yeah yeah back back in texas i could
make you know
uh like 120 all the way up to 300
dollars
a day but i'm a workaholic i will work
from 8 am to 9 pm
pretty much doing deliveries um recently
ever since i got to california though
youtube is kind of it's like a balance
now i can do half and half and i'm not
having to struggle as much with the
deliveries to keep myself afloat you
know
yeah so right now what are you doing on
deliveries like 70 bucks 60 or is it
still 100
a day uh pretty right in the middle
probably
50 to 100 bucks a day okay and how many
hours does that typically take
uh that's like a morning shift and a
night shift you know those are my two
primaries lunches
always whatever what is it is it the
tips are higher during breakfast and
lunch
yeah dinner yeah what's the most
ridiculous thing that you've seen
someone order
where you're just like i can't believe
they're paying seven dollars to get this
like
two dollar thing delivery or do you ever
see any of this like absurd orders where
you're you're
picking up like some 500 item for
somebody and like delivering it
like what's the craziest thing you've
seen uh
i had to pick up uh some makeup from
sephora one time that was
that was fun um uh
condoms a couple times no oh yeah how do
you how do you order those
uh i didn't know
how do they do that like through what
app uh that may have just been a texas
thing there's this other company where
you could essentially just
have whatever you want delivered to you
that's smart why doesn't la do that just
random items like
that i want something from rite aid
people in la are done with their money
you know for a fact an app like that
would just go wild
yeah great idea what about like just
crazy items that you that you pick up
what's the most expensive
one that you've ever delivered uh
so i got a 300 tip one time
in florida near miami and but that was
probably a 800 or 900
catering order oh catering yeah catering
yeah what were you catering uh it's
probably some italian food or something
i don't
i don't remember that's nuts yeah wow
i bet it's gonna get to the period where
like people will order something on one
of those food service apps
trying to get you to deliver it to them
i bet that's gonna happen
like you're gonna go on youtube to the
point where people are just gonna shoot
their shot and like try to get you to
send them is there any way where people
can request you specifically to deliver
to
them that's a good question i don't know
for like the the big companies like uber
and everything yeah
there should be a way to like i want the
same guy to bring my same stuff i don't
want nobody else
yeah you should be away yeah
like customer loyalty that's good yeah
um
that'd be sick but then what would that
mean for everyone else though
like you gotta be quick with your
deliveries and then people know they can
rely on imagine a bidding system
where like you would have a certain like
bid in place and people could outbid
to have you deliver the item that'd be
sick
wow that's neat okay so you do the food
services
and you do youtube is there any other
stream of income that you have but first
a quick word from our sponsor fundrise
in 2021 a truly diversified portfolio
needs more than the traditional mix of
stocks bonds and mutual funds it needs
private real estate
studies have shown that portfolios with
an allocation to private real estate
generally delivered a better risk
adjusted return
with more annual income and lower
volatility over the past two decades
with fundrise this level of powerful
diversification is now available to you
fundrise provides access to diversified
portfolios of private real estate to all
investors with their industry-leading
easy to use platform
whether you're looking to add stable
cash flow via dividends or prefer
long-term growth through appreciation
fundrise makes investing in private real
estate as easy as investing in stocks
bonds or mutual funds
see for yourself how 130 000 investors
have built a better portfolio with real
estate
it just takes a few minutes to get
started go to fundrise.com
iced coffee today that's fundrise
f-u-n-d-r-i-s-e
dot com iced coffee thanks so much and
back to the podcast
uh merch i do merch for the channel
okay um i'm about to sell out of that
though
really yeah congratulations thank you
yeah
i mean there there weren't big orders i
started with like a quantity of 30.
those sold out pretty quick friend's
family and then so i was like oh
well i'll get another 50. and uh it's
been several months that i've been
working on that stack
um and i'm just now finishing up that
right now wow
have you ever thought about doing
patreon uh a lot of the subs have told
me to do it but
i don't know because i i don't know i
put a lot of
pride into every single video and
editing and everything and i want
everyone to see it you know i don't want
to just put it on something i guess
restrictive i don't know if that's the
right word to use but um yeah i don't
think i make enough content
for that you know because it takes me a
while to put out a video
like this last the video that will go up
tomorrow
um i just spent all day yesterday and
half of today editing the whole thing
and so um and then i usually give myself
a day break and then film again and so
i don't know if i could do that but i've
definitely thought about it
isn't your time better spent right now
filming and editing than it is
spent doing like food services like that
i would say so
so you're making more per hour doing the
the editing and stuff like that
right um and i wanted to talk to you all
about this because uh
you know i recently had a video blow up
that's at like half a mil
and yeah i might is it okay if i say how
much i might make oh we
love that we were gonna ask that we're a
financial channel so of course
so i'm at like 3 700 right now
a month at least that's what my a month
on youtube
37 3 700 yes yeah a month
um but you know before that it was like
300 a month
and so i don't know if that actually
will continue to be that every month
maybe
or you set a new base your new base is i
bet you
your new base is at least a thousand at
least like 1500 at least
so what's your total then per month
right now because let's let's
call it three thousand youtube what's
your total right now for for food
delivery
uh a month you said yes sixty
times thirty was it eighteen hundred so
you're at forty eight hundred a month
let's just say
right now that's pretty good that's
insanely good now i'll tell you my
my thing is that uh i think some of the
appeal so far for your videos
is your unique situation and story
i think the food delivery provides
almost like a backdrop
for content for you to film from the car
i think is so different that people tune
in to you because
not only is your editing and
storytelling really good but it's also
just
an interesting topic that people really
just want to share it's so real and it's
real and i'm worried
like like it's it to grow that audience
beyond let's say now a hundred thousand
because that's i think your next big
marker
how can you capture that same audience
while still retaining that like
rawness of the video have you thought
about that or are you just taking it
like a day at a time
i think the audience would love to see
him like do be successful
and like buy like you know or be more
successful you know
i've definitely thought about that a lot
like if i do get to a point where i
so to say made it i guess you know like
where would i go
from there would people still watch me
yeah because uh
you know i'm at a point where if like i
i still feel like i'm struggling
um and i think people engage with that
and can relate to that you know
so um i haven't really thought that
through like you said
i'm just taking it a day at a time right
now so people will be happy to see
you spending money on things that you
enjoy and living a little bit more of a
lavish lifestyle i would
say i'm 95 certain of that yeah i know
as a viewer i would be really happy to
see that
so let me ask you this because i'm
almost thinking like if you were like at
what
point would you consider renting an
apartment right this second it's not
even a thought in my mind
do you you like living in the car i mean
is that your preference yes
i absolutely yeah why is that
i can go whenever i don't have to stay
in one place i can go go wherever i can
pretty much do
do whatever you know i i don't feel
trapped
you know or enclosed somewhere um
you know and i haven't quite figured out
where i would settle down if i
ever decided to like where would i get
get a place you know
yeah what about upgrading to like a
sprinter van or something like that
where you got some more space
uh so the only reason i probably
wouldn't do that is because
um it's it's big i don't like driving
anything bigger than a truck
yeah so about the sprinter van you don't
you wouldn't drive anything beyond a
truck
right now if i if i ever like got a
girlfriend or
met someone or something i think it'd
probably be a good idea to do that
but hopefully by that point if it ever
happened
um i wouldn't have to worry so much
about deliveries and i could just
do the van life thing you know that's
what i was thinking for you i think van
life would be ideal
i think i think a combination honestly
what about van life and scientists
he's right he's very right he's he's
right he's smiling this is what he
advises to every single guest
it's like this is your game this is you
you every single episode you go
so why not vegas like california and
then
you go over your vegas field and then
it's like what about van life what is
this
he's right that's true i'm not going to
say he's wrong he's very right that
would be very true
i think van life and side hustles you
find just
creative ways to make money living in a
van traveling across the united states
maybe go up to canada for a little bit
but just find
creative ways of making money like you
know mike rowe with dirty jobs
imagine if you were to document or try
out
just weird ways of making money like go
go through
louisiana and and you know fish for for
crawfish or something like that or
just different things i think would be
really interesting
yeah i don't i don't know how i feel
about it
i say just just do whatever you're
passionate about i think that you're
good enough at storytelling you're good
enough at like all the cinematography
and stuff like that
do whatever you want to do and i think
the viewers will appreciate that i feel
like if he does like a dirty job
disingenuous or something like that like
go somewhere to clean up poop somewhere
yeah yeah
i don't know you've already been through
it right like do you want to
pick up poop and stuff like that i don't
know i guess so
yeah it wouldn't be a bad idea and
make for a good video i'm going to poop
at this famous spot right here or
whatever you know
um fair enough so yeah let's talk a
little bit more about your living
situation it's really interesting to me
to live in a car where do you shower
where do you shave
how do you take care of all that stuff
so usually it's planet fitness
um you know that i have to pay 30
a month so i'm able to use any plant
fitness
um but obviously i can't do that here in
california
so i've been using the beach showers but
when i first got here i was using
pilots and i was putting a hole in my
wallet because i was having to pay
15 every time i would go to pilot
um like truck stop bathrooms um
super nice though like high pressure
really hot
you get your own bathroom for like two
hours and uh
but yeah it wasn't free so and shaving
and stuff you do that at the beach too
uh i actually did that yesterday at a
ralph's and uh
in the bathroom yeah yeah it was a
single-use bathroom and people kept
knocking on the door and i was like i
would come out and be like
uh i'm actually shaving uh you said that
to them yeah and uh
i would be like you can go ahead on you
can go in though and use the bathroom
i'll just come back in when you're done
and they're like okay that'd be funny
like waiting outside the
ralph's like bathroom with like shaving
cream all over your face like a razor
you know
do they not see the employees not saying
anything or they just as long as you're
not causing any trouble
then yeah no not never you know i
every time i go into a ralph so i gotta
ask for the bathroom code but they're
actually they're
usually like super cool about it you
know do you use the same ralphs or do
you
do different ralphs different different
routes okay
wow kind of just depends where i'm
working at the moment yeah
would you feel comfortable then talking
about your financials like where some of
your money is going and if you
are investing or what your plan is or
how you plan to
yeah uh so i've actually been listening
to you for like three years
no way are you serious yeah for sure no
way
i got youtube red just so i could hear
you while i'm driving around
yeah i had no idea yep there you go i'm
blown away thank you man
no problem um you've heard everything i
have to say then
please yeah um i i came here with the
intention of you uh
wanting to um what's the word
i don't want to say be my but uh react
critique critique critique me because i
have uh
no stocks like nothing like that um
but uh oh yeah that's what i was gonna
say i i drink
starbucks every morning
why it's under five dollars okay it's
it's only three 250 to three dollars why
because i
i just get the pike with whole milk and
that's hold on a second what about
mcdonald's they're like 7-eleven they
have coffee for like a dollar what's up
with that
points the starbucks points and then uh
also people
have been sending me starbucks gift
cards which i guess mcdonald's have
tasked gift cards too but they do uh
starbucks is good if you have a gift
card i don't think the rewards make it
cheaper
than a mcdonald's the only thing i think
with starbucks is that
what is it if you buy an espresso drink
someone was telling me this like some
crazy life hack you buy an espresso
drink
you can get a free refill on that it's
or like you can get a free refill on
like a certain thing
i forget what it was someone will
comment this in the description but it
actually worked out to be a pretty good
deal
if you get this certain drink but
mcdonald's has that but better
my friend i don't know if they still
have this or the exact numbers but back
in high school my friend
would have a mcdonald's coffee cup and
he would drink from it
and refill it and then clean it and like
bring it home
clean and everything and then bring it
back to mcdonald's and get a refill for
like 10
cents they don't reuse cups anymore
because of everything going on but they
will give you a new one
if you bring in the cup or if you just
yeah
okay uh yeah oh yeah you show them the
cup but they can't reuse the same cup
for sanitary reasons so they'll just
give you a new cup
so 250 a day why why do that though is
it just your thing every morning is just
like something to look forward to
the way i look at it is i'm paying for
the
convenience i guess it's easy just to
put in the order on
on your phone and then go pick it up and
then get right back
get get right to work you know so
yeah not the end but what about 711 or
mcdonald's would you go back to that if
you didn't have the cards because i know
it's like is one of the best deals yeah
coffee like on the go
if i have no other source of coffee
7-eleven is actually my go-to choice in
the big thing
circle k two yeah and they have all the
creams and you just get free
it's awesome so what i usually do is
7-eleven is get the big thing of coffee
like this for like 70 cents
you could take a whole bunch of creams
and then you could usually just get a
free cup of ice
take the coffee let it cool down a
little bit pour it over the iced iced
coffee 70 cents
good deal good deal great coffee you
love it
i'll have to look into that definitely
something to research right there oh
yeah
so why have you not gotten your for free
stocks from weeble also
what's up you're not investing because
i'm sure that you seem pretty frugal i
mean you do live in your car right so
like
you're pretty wise with your spending at
least it's not like out of control
what are you doing with your money is it
all just sitting in a chase i'm hoping
it's a high yield savings account i'm
hoping
so uh i do have a savings account with a
credit union
and then um i have a checking account
which is where
most of my money is right now and um
yeah i i have dabbled with weeble and
uh robin hood but um
i would always have to take the money
back out to pay bills
so i've played with it but i haven't
gotten serious about it what kind of
bills do you have
uh i have all my bills on my phone can i
can i let's see
all right let's let me look can you
screen record this
it's great yeah absolutely cool this is
all my bills all right so
we've got one month car 300 a month what
what is the 300 a month
is that a loan yes what's your loan
balance
uh two grand not that much how much did
you buy the car for when did you buy it
thirteen seven
thirteen thousand seven hundred right
when did you buy it uh like four years
ago you bought it used
yes it's not bad how many miles you have
on it
well a lot
like over i think 230
and you oh my gosh wow it's an acura
though it's a honda so
yeah they're going to last forever i
mean you get that car for like 500 000
miles on it
as long as you take care of it nuts all
right what do you know your interest
rate on that loan
uh uh 12. oh
wait i have it actually it better not be
twice i took a screenshot it would be
12.
i bet it would be 12. yep 12 percent oh
no okay so my first speech my first
piece of advice
is take nearly all the youtube income
and just pay down that loan because 12
interest
that's going to be higher than you would
make in the stock market or
investing in anything so you want to pay
off that car loan as fast as possible
that's right there is your priority
right now better paying that off than
investing it
yes that's smarter financial yes so in
this 3 800
a month i would probably take a thousand
of that let's say
and knock out half of that car loan and
then the next month
take another thousand knock it off
entirely be done with that carlo
okay that then you're gonna free up 300
bucks a month
okay sounds good but also i we probably
should probably talk about
my credit or okay and all of that
yeah or how much uh i o and
yeah which is kind of a big deal that
i'm having to deal with right now okay
that's what happened
yeah uh so i had like
i had really good credit at one point
and i i had like
four credit cards or something um you
know journey
capital one chase you name it whatever
um
and around that time is when i started
using drugs and i ended up having to use
well i chose to use those credit cards
for like hotels motels
and uh i racked up like 10 grand
okay do you obviously done is it at
least it's gotta be like 20
there's no way it's the credit card is
under 20 right
i have no idea okay uh
do you know your credit score now have
you paid them on time
uh oh no they're in collections
okay so for those not aware usually that
means when you're more than 180 days
late
uh they go to a they get sold off to a
third party collections agency
now how recent was that
years ago how many years do you know
two maybe three years ago that's not bad
yeah so you're at a 624 as
it's it i mean it's that's better than i
thought it would be better than i
thought it would be
yeah i thought he's gonna be in the 500s
um so let's talk about the credit really
quick
because let's say this was two years ago
the one option that some people take is
that
i'm just gonna let this go seven years
i'm not gonna care about my credit
i don't need to take out a loan so i'm
just gonna wait the seven years and
eventually it's gonna fall off my credit
report
so you have that option there uh the
other option
if you think within the next five years
four years you might
want to get another loan where you might
want to
get a mortgage or something or rent in
apartments anything where they will
require you to run your credit
you have the option to take some of your
money and then negotiate
with the accounts and collections and
you could say i owe 10 grand
but i'll pay you right now i got three
grand well you take
three thousand dollars and in turn
remove this from my credits
from my credit report uh usually those
debt collection agencies
will buy like a hundred dollars worth of
debt like a dollar
and then they just go after you calling
you incessantly
and whatever they make above a dollar is
their profit uh but they charge off
so uh so many of these loans that for
them
if they collect one out of every 10
they're making money so
you could go in knowing that for 10 000
of debt they probably paid i don't know
like
600 bucks 500 bucks for that so anything
more than that's their profit
usually so you can negotiate with them
and you could you could try
and if you can't come to an agreement so
be it
but i would i would probably depending
on how youtube does
if youtube really takes off and you're
like consistently making
you know three four or five grand a
month i would take a chunk of that and
try to negotiate with them to remove
that from your credit history
i see and you get to always get it in
writing too really important to get that
in writing
okay um would you suggest paying that
off over time
or because in my head i was like i'm
just gonna
keep hustling or whatever and make try
and save up 10 grand and then just pay
it off all at once
if they're in collections they bought
that for way less than 10
you don't need to pay them 10. you could
probably end up just
throwing it you could probably pay them
like three maybe less
start with less say you have two so you
have two grand well you take two to
erase this and they'll be like no we
can't we need all ten
okay i might be able to get like 22 23.
negotiate with them
have them come back have them come back
in writing and say for three thousand
dollars we will
get rid of all of this debt we will take
this in consideration of all the debt
that you have and we'll remove this from
your report in collections
okay but get that in writing so it's up
to you
i mean the other alternative like i said
is waiting five years
and it will go off your credit report
wow five years
yeah okay i think if youtube does well
it's worth it
let that be in the past pay it off not
entirely negotiate with that but let
that be in the past and and
improve your credit okay yeah that
sounds good
but yeah if it were something current i
would say you could do a
balance transfer to a zero percent
interest credit card but in collections
unfortunately can't do that
okay so but besides the accountant
collection nothing else on credit cards
you pay that off in full
um no i don't think so okay just make
sure it's
just make sure auto so automatically
when the bill is due
just take it from your checking account
okay well i'd have to do that in the
future
right because like right now my apps
don't even
like register because all of the dep is
in collections
yeah so this would be so not for the
a collections account but for any new
debt that you have on the credit card
or on a future credit card just anything
you pay with credit cards right now
no it's all checking yeah okay okay so
you'll probably
i would recommend at this point you
could probably sign up for a
discover it's secured card it's one of
my favorite cards i i think for for your
credit score your situation
what you would do get a discover it
secured card just go and apply for it
you'll put down a 300 uh deposit
they'll give you back a 300 credit line
all you need to do on that credit card
is just put your starbucks on the card
every day and then pay it off every week
just whatever the balance is
pay it off in full but just put the
starbucks on the credit card
and do that for five six months okay
that's gonna dramatically help your
credit score
discover it's secure guys say right
after this go and apply for it 300
deposit and i'll say two years from now
you'll look back and you'll be so happy
you did that
awesome i'll do it at least yeah of
course and what are your other monthly
let's see i saw
car insurance but first a quick word
from our sponsor ladder life insurance i
remember when i bought a weekly call
option on tesla and made like 400
in two days it was absolutely amazing
that experience reminded me of how
beautiful life really is and that it
should be protected on that note it
makes sense why people get life
insurance
especially long-term coverage which is
surprisingly affordable why not pay a
little bit each month to protect the
ones that you love
if you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder ladder makes it
impressively fast and easy to get
covered you just need a few minutes a
phone or a laptop to apply latter's
smart algorithms work in real time so
you'll find out instantly if you're
approved there are no hidden fees and
you can cancel any time and since life
insurance costs more as you age
now's the best time to cross it off your
list so check out ladder today to see if
you're instantly approved go to
ladderlife.com
iced coffee that's ladd er life
dot com slash iced coffee ladderlife.com
iced coffee thank you so much and back
to the podcast
yeah car insurance 180. that's not bad
i would say for the amount of driving
you do how many how many miles would you
say you drive every
every month ooh every month uh
3 000 a month on uh full work days i can
drive 120 miles wow
so i mean maybe let's
say 75 times 30 for uh how much i drive
a month
miles wise wow okay so decent amount i'd
say good car insurance
gas 600 that's exactly what i would
expect
yeah uh oil change 60 that's not
terrible okay so phone one 115
what do you have for your phone why is
that so high uh a t
and i'm making poem payments on this
phone right here so
uh okay all right so that makes sense um
and then itunes 16
music for when i'm driving around
youtube to listen to graham while i'm
playing
that's fine uh planet fitness 30. um
rent is free okay uh insurance like it's
like this weird health insurance i have
that uh i pay 20 a month and i get back
after the whole entire payment is
complete but i forget
how much uh i pay until yeah
it's done but uh food 500 maybe
yeah wait but the reason why is it it's
hard for you to cook food
like you can't necessarily cook food at
home what do you eat
uh so if i do eat in the morning it's
like a nutri grain bar
or something protein something you know
um
every once in a while i like to go to or
i'll go and get a bacon egg and cheese
from either
egg [ __ ] or mcdonald's or something and
then lunch i try to keep it healthy and
cheap like i'll go to ralph's and go to
like the deli section
and either like get a sandwich or uh
some pasta or something that's usually
under five dollars
and like a banana or something you know
so i think that's
that's one thing with having like a
refrigerator and an oven you could
probably get that food bill from 500 to
200.
so there's 300 bucks extra that you're
paying as a premium
for really not having to do your own
cooking right but the good thing is
of your hundred and seventy dollar total
budget every month
a lot of that's a business expense the
interest you on the car that's a
write-off for you
car insurance is a write-off gas is a
write-off oil change write-off phone
write-off um nearly everything is a
write-off for you
so for 1870 you got to think too that's
expensive for living in your car
1870 but i think a lot of that too is
just gas
yeah yeah so
it's it's uh it's definitely something
where it's it's higher than what i would
like to
to see but uh honestly i think the car
payment just pay that you're only two
grand away
so that'll bring it down 300 bucks and
it'll be at uh you'll be at 1500.
1500 is a good goal to be at yeah try to
get it around 15.
okay and how much do you have in savings
right now
uh like 2200 like two two grand
okay so i would say i mean i would
almost just take the dave ramsey
approach with this is save up
six months worth of expenses so 1500
times six
so what what 7 500 or no no
9 000 9 000 bucks is it really yeah
fifteen hundred times six no it's not
fifteen hundred why
why can't i math right now i i'm leaving
a second
i'm leaving this in nine thousand
it is nine thousand why don't i know
that i i can't do basic math
so nine thousand i would put and save
nine thousand dollars in a high interest
savings account um
do you know what your credit union is
offering uh i don't think so
okay my recommendation would be ally
bank
go get ally bank that would be my
recommendation um you'll earn like half
a percent in interest i mean it's not
going to be
a lot or you got a bank uh would you
want
me to move what's in my savings right
now and put that in there or just
completely start oh you know what
you can't do that because yada doesn't
have the checking feature right now
so i would say for you given your
situation right now
a yada will eventually come out with the
checking feature
so for i don't want to tell you put your
money in there and then you can't pay
bills with it
um it's coming soon guys but until then
i'd say probably ally bank would be a
better choice because you would have
access to a totally free checking
account totally free savings account
you can set up everything on automatic
bill pay they'll give you free checks
free debit card and that would probably
set you up
i'd say fairly well i'm sure the credit
union's good
but you might be able to do a little
better with ally okay
once you get i would say past 9000
once you get collections taken care of
i'd say at that point you could
start investing but then i'm also
thinking like in terms of investments
your best investment might just be in
getting better equipment
just like um maybe maybe adding a
different camera angle
or editing software a faster computer
like something like that
might get you a much higher roi than i
think a traditional investment
i've been thinking about that i do need
another computer it takes
me forever to make the videos i do you
know
um yeah where do you charge your your
equipment and stuff like that
i have this like little um cigarette
adapter that
plugs into my car and then um you can
just put
outlets into it pretty much but i've
been looking into getting uh
like something apart side from the car
just so i
am not using the car's battery as often
but it's weird because i find things on
amazon
but i can't have it sent to my p.o box
because of battery acid
stuff like that um and then when i go to
these like electronic stores what they
have is crap
compared to what's online pretty much
to get the best bargain so i'm trying to
figure that out right now as far as
charging my stuff goes but do you ever
run out of the car battery because i did
that once before
uh with you plugged in the computer and
the battery ran out
uh not very not very often um i always
get warranties on my batteries
just recently probably a couple weeks
ago i had to change the battery but
it was cheap so nice that's funny they
probably don't think that you're living
in your car when they're selling you the
batteries
no probably not until they see the
passenger seat it's not like
geez no but um
so i want to know if you were making
five thousand dollars a month pretty
consistently with
youtube and all all your like income
sources do you think that you would want
to live in a house or an apartment or
would you continue living in your car
i would definitely continue living in my
car as of
right this second when i'm still
enjoying it i'm not really sure when
when
i'll ever decide to get a place you know
so even if given the opportunity to live
elsewhere you would prefer to live in
your car
right why why do you think that is
was there something that happened that
that you didn't want to feel trapped
because i i do see your point of view
of just the freedom of not having stuff
and just being able to pick up
and go anywhere you want to i mean
that's that's got to be just so
liberating that
very few people have that but i also
like coming
like having your spot that you come back
to every day
yeah i mean that that's pretty much me
every time i get in my car yeah
it doesn't really matter where i'm at
you know
um have you always been like that
uh that's that's a good question
not yeah i mean i'm super i guess you
could say like introverted and so i've i
there's always some sort of safe spot
for me you know that i like to go to
where i can just
breathe and relax and um
i guess that that used to be a friend's
house or
my parents when i used to live with them
but i guess now it's just
my car and it just doesn't really depend
where i'm parked but
got it speaking of your parents uh do
you feel comfortable talking about
just your relationship with them do they
worry about you living in the car what's
i think at first they did yeah but
they're so used to it now and they see
what i'm doing like with
with the channel and uh i think it makes
a little bit more sense to them now
than it did when i first started uh
so you know i'm sure they have you know
the
parent warning you know uh what's it
called
worries worries um but
i think they see what i'm trying to do
and and they're okay with it
what did you think you were gonna be
doing like 10 years ago did you have a
like like a goal or did you want to be
like a
something out like a doctor or anything
or yeah psychiatrist really
yeah or some sort of therapist okay
and why didn't you pursue that uh
college wasn't my thing i guess but um
also um when i
enrolled in
you know when cats just anything that's
on a table they just
yeah what was the need like ramsay no
need to push it so far yeah he doesn't
like
anything on the table that's within his
vicinity so he'll just be like
if it's in his bubble he's got to get
rid of it it's
all done and then he could rest there
yeah i mean
uh as soon as i graduated high school is
when my drug use started
so my first semester in college was was
used
or was spent using using drugs and so
and then i've been in and out of college
pretty much ever since then
um but i don't know i just it was never
my thing i always tried
to invent ideas in my own head to make
money pretty much
would you mind talking a little bit more
about the the drug use and maybe how
that's impacted you and your perspective
now how did that get yeah how did that
get started
uh pretty much um like one of my closest
friends
in the world had been dealing with it
for a long time
and um you know i was hanging
around him a while while he while he was
doing it and so
it eventually became uh normalized to me
as if like us or you know californians
see uh marijuana or whatever like they
see it they don't think
anything of it i guess that's how um my
drug of choice was
for for me um and so one night i was
just at his place and
i saw and was like oh well let me try it
and uh
yeah downhill from there like an
immediate connection to the drug like
did it immediately stimulate you and
make you want more of it or was it just
kind of like
usage over time like you said you were
kind of um you became accustomed to it
and it wasn't that big of a deal for you
so like maybe you thought oh a little
here and there won't hurt and then that
over time started making you develop a
reliance on it that's definitely how how
it started in the beginning
like um a lot of people say just one hit
or whatever
that i mean that that is the case for
some people but for me
it took it took us like a month or so
you know to be like
i actually like this um but i think i
i kept pursuing it because i was already
dealing with
mental illness issues it helped with my
anxiety
it helped with my depression you know
the dopamine levels that you get off of
off of it just are through the roof and
so i was like
i feel like the a better version of
myself you know
and uh that's pretty much why i
continued to use it for
eight years you know how did you wean
yourself off of that
um a lot of uh
i think the most important thing for me
is just uh friends and family
good there's support i'm always having
someone to talk to
having some sort of you know support
group that you can call
every single day i'm struggling with
this or i'm struggling with that today
um that's probably been the the biggest
thing for me going to rehab three times
definitely helped too
uh just by meeting people and uh
learning new methods as to stay sober
yeah
what now what what happened after the
first two times that you were there that
didn't
quite click as the third time so the
first time
it was uh almost kind of against my will
like i was uh my drug dealer was
actually the one who told me i needed a
rehab wow
so uh he got me it was it was spur at
the moment he was like just one day hey
i got you
a flight to miami you're going to to
rehab and i was like
what and i just found myself on a plane
got through the 45 days of rehab and
then
uh came back home flew back home and
immediately relapsed
because i wasn't ready you know um
and so i went through a second time i
actually drove my car
um across the country um after i got
back home after relapsing because
i realized oh i just wasted 45 days of
my life
um just to come back home and relapse
and so
i gathered all all my stuff and went
back to the rehab
and uh did another 45 days and
after that i stayed in like halfway
houses and
really tried to get my my crap together
in florida um and it got to a point
where
a couple months go by and i'm like i
think i'm i'm cured or whatever
and uh and so i go back home no still
wasn't time to go back home
and uh yeah it was a repetitive
cycle for like a year a year or two you
know
i have a couple questions um so you went
and you
relapsed after you went to the rehab
place for the first time
when you relapsed did that same drug
dealer that send you there
give you like the new drugs for you to
relapse
uh no i don't think he did
yes okay because that confused me i was
like why would anyone do that
and also you say like cured like this
do you it seems like you have something
to say about i don't think anybody's
ever cured
my that's my understanding right yeah
you can't
so what's your take on that you think
that if you go through it once then it's
something it's a constant battle
throughout your life and you don't think
that you'll
be able to you know unattach yourself
from that
there's a lot of different uh ways to to
think about that
but um i would just say it's uh
definitely something that is in the back
of my head
for it that i feel like it's going to
have an
like an everlasting effect on me i don't
know if that makes sense but yeah it
does
and how has your usage of that drug
changed your perspective
now do you think that all although
obviously
i'm sure that that that period of time
in your life is really difficult and
terrible
um now do you think that you have like
an elevated
uh perspective on life and stuff like
that because of
you know that usage and then maybe the
hard times that followed do you think
that that's changed your perspective now
for the good absolutely yeah i see
people differently
um you know i think it it really
even changed my my personality a lot um
in what way um
you know i was just like a really shy
like way over
insecure type of person before using
drugs and drugs put me in
a lot of situations where
i couldn't be that way i completely had
to change my perspective on
how i acted and everything and so going
through those
tough times absolutely has kind of
shaped me into the person i am today
you know like even being here right now
you know like this is
this is pretty mind-blowing i don't know
if i would have done something like this
if i hadn't have
gone through my my hardships prior you
know
probably be at home or something at my
parents house
just like in in the corner or something
depressed so
that's that's interesting you're
definitely going to go far on youtube
i really feel guys sub to his channel i
know please for the love of god we're
putting it we're putting in the
description link down below sub to
jake's channel all right
show them some love okay sub to this
channel
it's way too high yeah 66 percent yeah
so chances are
uh we're talking to somebody who is yet
to subscribe on the channel
yeah statistics please guys we're trying
to get 100 000. we need to get a 100k
i need i really want to play i know
julia jeff wants the plaque so guys just
even if you're
just just just subscribe thank you
subscribe to jack finally get his silver
play button
so much the first one's a hundred right
a thousand hundred
that would be really cool yeah oh yeah
can i see your youtube analytics can we
can we see it
all right can you do you mind screen
recording it yeah cool i do have one
more quick question though about our
last subject
um do you think that you cannot help
someone who doesn't want to be helped
or do you think that you can it's just
small chances small chances
so it's still possible you think uh
yeah i think it's still possible i would
just say that
don't ever stop being supportive if
someone's out there struggling
and you know they they have no means of
stopping
it's still it's still good for that
person to know that there's someone that
they can reach out to regardless of what
they're going through
it's a piece of advice is it ever good
to get like tough love
in the sense of like you gotta cut
somebody out absolutely
at what point do you resort to that um
i just recently had someone reach out to
me and and they were like my son is is
struggling
um i keep giving him money for for food
and everything and i'm like
he's not he's probably not using that
money for food
you know and those are always a really
tough uh
conversations but i would just say just
you can't
give in you can't continue to give an
addict money you know
um yeah but you never know what the
what the background story is and so it's
always so you think it depends on the
situation
you shouldn't enable but you should
support what emotionally
or with your time be there i think that
makes sense
yeah so let's see okay yeah so we're
almost at 25 000 subscribers can i
uh do you mind if i see yeah okay let me
see i want to see this
we got a 4 out of 10 nice i just want to
go to analytics
wow look at this getting a little push
consistent
wow that's the algorithm very consistent
oh man
look at that you see those little pushes
and on on an upward trend
oh no this is it this is the video that
i got pushed my first week living in los
angeles california working ubereats
postmaster dash
that was the video yep that was that was
what got pushed for me
do you have any questions for us uh
what can we do for you uh am i allowed
to talk about um
anything kevin and grant cardone the
flower gosh
anything anything you want and uh
whatever i can't talk about we want to
talk about it okay
that was uh that was super fun shout out
me kevin
kevin what's up man how's it going yeah
i made one of my christmases one to
remember definitely because uh
he uh me and like half a dozen or a
dozen people went to
do the flower operations were there i
have a video for it that got taken
taken down you were one of the elves
yeah oh
wow no way have you talked to kevin no
kevin is the one who got me out of the
situation
i can send that to him right now he got
you out of what situation uh grass
subpoenaed me in sued kevin
and kevin got me out of the subpoena
have you been speaking to him recently
uh he shouted me out on his channel like
a week ago
wow yeah i love kevin
um what what doesn't kevin have done
every person we bring on here they've
already had past experiences with kevin
we're like how did you get to everything
for us man wow
that blows my mind this is like two
years ago too this is
wow how did you meet him uh kevin just
posted something on his social media
and instagram yeah looking for elves in
florida so what happened with that
so how did grant get your information to
subpoena how did that happen
i have no idea about that i received a
letter
and it's i just took a picture of it and
sent it to kevin and
kevin pretty much made it magically go
away for me
so yeah so chances are kevin has a
lawyer who's who
he's paid a big deposit to who's
handling anything for him
right now and uh knowing kevin he would
gladly pay out of pocket
uh for any any attorney just to make
sure everything's okay
good for him wow yep can't say enough
good things about kevin
every podcast he's a missing one it's
like we're talking about kevin in
every single i don't get it
[Laughter]
jeez all right wow uh let me see what
else he's a saint
he is insane he is he's surprising me
every day he's not
he's not even here no
that's pretty much it okay so we
naturally covered most of the things we
wanted to talk about yeah yeah
i think i'm most excited just to see
your journey i am
really excited just to see where you're
going to be five years from now
because i know with your storytelling
through editing with your video you're
really talented um and if
the very few people i say that about
when it when especially when it comes to
like youtube video
um erack was another one where yeah
you just knew yeah you met him it's like
instantly he's gonna do it and he did
uh and i had without no doubts in my
mind he's gonna hit a million
subscribers
yeah by the end and he did no doubt in
my mind he did i have no doubt in my
mind
that uh i know you're gonna hit a
hundred thousand i know
you're gonna do youtube full-time uh i
think you could do a million
uh i don't know when but i'm fairly
confident that would happen
as long as you just consistently make
content and vlogs and
what's your current posting schedule
right now twice a week yeah
okay yeah about twice a week i'm
wondering you get it three times a week
if your your channel's just gonna blow
up
are you ever worried about bringing each
video up a notch
and making the next one better than the
previous one oh i'm constantly thinking
about that
i think that's a smart thing to be
considering yeah so you always have that
forwards momentum
i also want to know like what's your
game plan have do you think about like
the next five years the next 10 years
where would you like to see yourself in
the next
five years because is it living in a car
still uh
five years from now i'm not sure um i've
actually always wanted to
get into investing in in real estate um
two of my closest friends back home are
our realtors and and
they're kind of they've kind of got
their own llc doing
doing their thing over there and um yeah
i mean pretty much
my my whole entire plan this whole time
has been save as much money as possible
and put it back in
into real estate but other than that i
it yeah it's f it's funny you won't live
in real estate but you will buy it
yeah you want nothing nothing to worry
about yeah yeah yeah you can't even i
mean you're just taking house hacking to
an extreme by just not living in that
house
i would literally get a house and then
just rent it out and continue living in
my car
what about a tent like in the backyard
or like you rent the house but you're
like hey i just want to camp in the
backyard
no temperature control gotcha
wow that's fantastic well listen for
real estate your credit is going to be
the biggest thing credit and income
you'll have the income set you're saving
most of it
i honestly think two years from now
you'll be you'll be making over a
hundred thousand a year
i really believe it um you just keep
making youtube videos and i think
you'll consistently you'll start getting
like 50
60 70 000 views per video consistently
you'll you'll make over 100 grand
yeah um and march for me has always been
a
very low profit margin business and it's
just
it's a lot of hassle to sell merch um
you might want to look into a patreon um
some sort of just alternative community
where people who want to support
you can doesn't mean you're going to
have to hold back content from people
but even if it just means you throw a
thank you at the end of the video
or you list their name in the
description or something like that for
like 10 bucks a month
so many people would want to support you
and just
see you on the come up so i think that
would be a good idea i think
i i would do a patreon because that
would at least bring in another 500
bucks a month
okay i'll look into it and consider some
ideas
consider it um what other income sources
do you think we can we could think of
here i just i think that patreon is the
smartest way to go
yeah patreon yeah because it would
really like consolidate a lot of your
work to just like filming and editing
oh i got it i'd say when you hit five
hundred thousand
you could begin teaching people how to
how to uh edit like editing
[Music]
they had the uh the art of storytelling
um
you could you could come out with
something of of just
vlogging the art of vlogging or the art
of cinematography or something like this
like imagine something if casey neistat
came out with the chorus
oh he'd make some oh man i guarantee
he'd probably make like five ten million
bucks
yeah just creating a course on how to
vlog sell for 99 bucks
he would be 10 million yeah
so you could look and do i think
education is always going to be such a
big
uh place and for opportunity
and not only would you be providing
value to other people but they would be
paying you
right so realistically i think right now
if you wanted to just increase your
income
i would say just stop doing the doordash
and stuff like that and instead
do a patreon because realistically i'm
sure that you could easily make you know
1500
a month from patreon i think it's very
very
like reasonable and also i think the
good part is you wouldn't have to worry
about that whole like new aspect of your
life
of uh like um going out and delivering
food and stuff like that you just worry
about filming getting content and that's
just on your mind you don't have to
worry about unless you just deliver it
almost as like a
part of a story as part of a narrative
of something like a schedule that you do
every day where you just
even if you just deliver mornings or
just evenings and you can make
make something of that and intertwine
that with your story i think would be
really interesting
right that's pretty much what i've been
doing lately it's like just create a
story film and then at the end of the
night
run a couple of deliveries or whatever
yeah um but yeah
so as far as patreon goes if y'all think
that that's a good idea how
how exactly does does that work i'm sure
a lot of people are actually curious
about this
as well like um normal upload schedule
for youtube and then just
try and bust out another video patreon
would be like behind the scenes if
you're making a full-on youtube video
i'd say just post it on youtube
patreon will be behind the scenes stuff
stuff that you don't want to post on
youtube maybe to
you know to ruin the algorithm but like
extra exciting footage that yeah
i'm sure you cut out a lot of stuff
maybe just all the cutout footage that
you're not going to use you put it up on
patreon or
it could be as simple as you're just
you're paying 10 a month you're
supporting
my channel and in return your name is
going to be in the description
yeah you can do stuff like stuff like
that or at the end of the video you'll
have a credits
thank you for my patreon supporters and
you put a credits wow and then like
every few videos you just add on to it
something like that okay yeah and and
what you could even do is do
a a random shout out like once a video
uh
randomly shout out the socials of one of
your patreon members you'll be like hey
today it came up like uh
john what's up john here it is thanks so
much and
something like that i think just people
like that but no nobody's really
paying ten dollars a month because
you're like we need a content we need
they're doing because they want to
support you
so i think that's the most important
thing is that people who want to
support you like that have a means too
okay
do you want to be a youtube creator for
the rest of your life like is that where
you see yourself
um
hmm i'm not sure
right this second like i can see myself
doing it for a long time
but i don't know if i could see see
myself doing it forever you know
um eventually i would just like to
rent out a whole bunch of of houses and
just chill i think
um but yeah the main reason why i
started the channel in the in the first
place was just to pretty much document
my life
i'm just doing it more often now i'm
putting it on youtube for the world to
see
so uh i don't know we'll have to see
what
comes about life pretty much right and
we've also given you
plenty of unsolicited advice can you
give us
some advice and we're easily offended by
the way so just very
easily yeah uh i mean as far as
anything i mean i guess i've never heard
graham talk much about
uh you know maybe some of the uh things
that go on in the
in the background or behind the scenes
maybe
i'm sure people would love to hear about
maybe some of the the struggles that
happen behind the scenes or something
like that that's different
i've never been offered uh that piece of
advice but that's a good that's a good
point i
i have not that's good do you want to
talk about any of that graham
probably not now probably
um yeah no i definitely try to keep just
very business focused on the main
channel
like i've had such a format for all of
it and this is like the most relaxed
tend to be for youtube but maybe it's
some so you're saying he should be more
vulnerable is basically what you're
saying yeah it's better worded
vulnerable a little more transparent
yeah i'm worried that like where do i
post it on the main channel i know i'm
gonna i know
like i'm gonna get some really great
supporters on there but i'm gonna get a
lot of people like
oh don't post it on the main channel no
i know but like but
even the second channel the podcast man
podcast
this is where we talk about anything
this is not where we are
confined to finance this is about
everything
confronting graham stefan yes that's
good that's fair
that's that's fair okay all right
that's that's a good piece of advice i
definitely think that that would also be
good for
branding as well you know because people
get to know you a little bit more all
right
graham's just uncomfortable he's like
all right what's next what's next
talk about no because there's some stuff
it's just like you you don't want to air
out your dirty laundry like you don't
want to be talking about some of the
stuff that
you know i also i think for a lot of
people if you aren't super transparent
people see that and then they make
assumptions and oftentimes their
assumptions
are worse than the actual truth yeah so
that's why i like to try to be
pretty transparent with things because
the things i'm scared about people
knowing
you know what they could be thinking
could be 10 times worse
you know my favorite quote from you is
uh i don't really talk to girls
that's graham likes that quote yeah
we were thinking about making merch
where it just says i don't really talk
to girls on it
is that what you said i could see like
jack manley wearing that shirt yeah
he would do so well with that imagine
jack manley goes to like
bourbon street with like i don't really
talk to girls that would be cool what's
the story behind that
all right jack i don't even remember
this honestly i think i tried to block
it from my memory
uh oh the the quote that i don't really
talk to yes
how was that i don't even know who the
guest was i don't remember
the guest i just oh kong was it kong
was it kong i don't know i don't know i
don't know who it was we had someone on
the podcast
jack was going through his his online
profile
and something if someone will find it
and point it down in the description
no a lot of guys they uh they don't like
when girls are being
presumptuous when they try to be nice
even if they're flirting yeah
have you exp experienced that i haven't
but maybe i'm just
i don't really talk to girls i don't
know people just in the comments i
remember them liking that comment yeah
that was a wild episode sometimes these
episodes get a little out of hand
yeah i think the top comment was um i
don't really talk to girls and then
the response to that was like this hits
home
our viewers relate this hit's too close
to home we're like yeah
we appreciate the advice i think i think
uh we'll look into that a little bit
perfect yeah i i will next episode guys
if
you want to see the next just subscribe
yeah i'll be more vulnerable the next
one
well thank you so much man really
appreciate it kevin texted me back
he says uh love this guy
elf attack will go down in infamy huge
thank you to jake enjoy the podcast
well so that's kevin stephen two of my
favorite youtubers is tantra three
with jack this is crazy oh man
you really appreciate it thank you it's
been amazing it was awesome meeting you
we wish you the best of luck please
subscribe to jake everyone
and uh yeah yeah oh make sure to get
your four free stocks down below in the
description you can also sign up for
yada bank
you'll get a hundred entries into the
next drawing where you could earn up to
10 million dollars you may as well just
do it
um because it's it's free it doesn't
cost you anything uh
weeble's 100 but you get four free
stocks and uh with that said guys
uh yeah until next time 66 hit that
subscribe button and like button
thanks until next time go on
what's up i'm jake and this is the
34th ever 34th
ever episode of the iced coffee hour so
far
the podcast is made two thousand the
most the only things you need is
what's up i'm jake 34th ever you need to
ever
and then uh 32 000. what's up guys it's
jake
and this is the 34th episode of the hour
coffee
what's up guys it's jake and this is the
34th
ever episode of the
iced coffee hour iced coffee my oh
that's your phone's
iced coffee hour okay what's up guys
it's jake
and this is the 34th ever
ever